charlie morton should have
everything working for him today he's on
a real tear he has not faced the
nationals this year but has made 10
starts against them in his career he's
three and two
with a 398 era trey turner steps in
swung on missed
off speed got him one down
you get a swing and miss on trey turner
like that you know that ball's doing
something tonight's two-hole hitter for
the nationals is josh harrison next
pitch swung on ground ball toward the
hole swanson trying to backhand and
can't come up with it it's out in the
left field runner board with one up and
here's the aforementioned soto so when i
say he's been struggling taking his
walks but in the slugging category which
is what they want him to do if slugging
percentage is only 3.85 3-1 pitch to
soto's too low ball four nationals have
a chance right here in the first inning
runners first and second one out bell in
the cleanup spot stands in nationals
batting average with runners in scoring
position has dropped to 237 30 count
pitch
he was green light and he drives that
ball toward left almante is there and
makes the catch holds the runners at
first and second and now two out brings
up kyle schwarber swing on miss there's
another strikeout
schweiber has plenty of those
and charlie morton into and out of first
inning trouble face off with joe ross
two and four on the year jeff a 519 era
yeah and it's kind of funny because the
two starts
he gave up 18 runs and eight in the
third his other seven starts two and two
with the one eight doing pretty well
against the braves back on may fourth
gave up two runs and five and a third
ronald acuna steps in three-game hitting
streak little check swing tapper to the
open right side racing over his harrison
bare hand picked throw didn't get him
and excuse me single for ronald acuna
that was awesome
i love it
keep shifting so a good start for the
braves
and here's freeman over his last five
off the plate inside ball four
so the braves are setting up shop here
in the first inning against joe ross the
braves have runners on first and second
with nobody out
he's the hitter off the plate outside
four and the bases are loaded with
nobody out for austin reilly just what
the doctor ordered for atlanta well for
braves offense it's been kind of up and
down in may it's been nothing but up for
austin reilly and the pitch swung online
drive caught by harrison he looks but
nowhere to double anyone off so first
out on a line drive where harrison
position could catch it and that's a
break for ross because he stunned that
baseball now dansby swanson riding an
eight-game hitting streak stands in
driven in the air toward right soto
going back to the track he's gonna have
room there's the catch acuna will tag
and streak home sac fly for dansby
swanson and the braves score first it's
one to nothing and here's abraham
almante switch hitter batting left and
he takes a walk three walks of the
inning and they're loaded again and the
braves have reloaded the bases for
william contreras contreras no hits in
his last 13 tries the pitch is lined
softly in the left center that's down
for a hit that'll score two a two run
single on an o2 count and the braves
lead it three to nothing two men out
horadius stepping in swung on and popped
up
shallow right solo playing shallow
coming in is there and he makes the
catch to retire the side
eight men bat for atlanta the braves
scored three runs
on just
two hits ronaldo cunha jr bats for the
second time four for eight with one home
run against jill ross in the air that's
wallop to right somos
long gone
opposite field
line drive laser into the chop house
arm run number 16 for ronald lacuna
junior and the braves are pouring it on
at this level you give the other team
any little opening where they can get
their foot in the door it can hurt big
time we'll see if it happens here next
up is the switch hitting josh bell
josh bell high in the air deep left
center
c
u
later and the gnats are on the board any
door any opening major league players
will enter through it runners at first
and third and two out so here's joe ross
real chance to help himself he has two
rbis this year and a swing at a line
drive base hit right field for joe ross
he has done it again castro will score
it's now atlanta four in the nationals
three now you've got the top of the
order and trey turner coming up that
one's tipped and caught turner has the
hat trick in his first three trips we'll
see if ross can have the shutdown ending
here in the bottom of the fourth facing
the lower third of the braves order the
2-2 struck him out blew a fastball by
him at 92. that is strikeout number four
for joe ross since giving up the homer
to acuna ross has settled in to retire
six in a row check swing on a slider and
tom hallian says he went did not ask for
an appeal the home plate umpire rings
him up and ross has back-to-back
strikeouts here in inning four swinging
a miss down he goes on the slider so
ross strikes out the side giving him six
k's through four innings two on and two
out for the nationals and starlin castro
coming up trying to give him every
chance to leave this ball game in line
to get the w pitch
breaking ball line drive to left almante
is there and that will retire washington
charlie borton has the lead and a chance
to win the nationals have the time run
at third trailing four to three well
that leaves the inning up to trey turner
turner happy to see charlie morton out
of the game three times up turner struck
out three times he got him it's a four
strikeout game for trey turner great job
pitching around the air by luke jackson
already a chance now with two on and two
out already has been good in run scoring
spots for the braves right back up the
middle in the center of base hit that's
gonna score dansby another two strike
two out hit from guillermo heredia the
braves extend the lead is five to three
he walked him and acuna is coming up
with the bases loaded all this with two
outs
this is what they came to see right here
finnegan and acuna junior have faced
each other just once a ground ball rbi
the runners go the 3-2
strike three called over the outside
corner finnegan may have caught a break
there
as hallian rings up acuna on a pitch
maybe a hair outside but the inning
comes to an end
will smith their left-handed closer is
eight for eight
in save opportunities victor robles is
going to lead things off as a pinch
hitter and swinging a high fly ball
shallow right field long run acuna still
coming still coming he's there he's got
it one down two to go simple bat here
with no one on and one out as zimmerman
swung to the ball in the dirt smith got
him with a slider two outs
the brains are one out away from winning
their 25th game two out nobody on and
trey turner the last hope for the
nationals swinging a drive to center
field back is in ciarate plenty of room
this one is over it is a happy memorial
day in atlanta
the braves are within a game of 500.